welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important as entrepreneurs
to thank the people in your life who
have helped you with your business
because you can't do this alone and even
if it's just a friendly ear to talk to
sometimes that can make the difference
between you staying in business and and
quitting and going back in the job
so today i want to thank ed and ed is my
web host provider and it may be strange
to thank your web host provider but ed
has had a huge impact on my business
before i met ed and went with him
i was having a lot of problems with my
website
we were getting so much traffic that we
were crashing the servers it kept going
down i didn't know how to fix it you
know i'm not a technical person on the
server back end and i didn't understand
what the problem was i didn't know how
to fix it i only knew that my website
was down and when i called them i
couldn't understand what was happening
it's like this is my business my i need
my website up
i'm frustrated thinking back to that
time
and so i looked at different options and
i started talking to companies who were
known for their customer service and and
i was just underwhelmed and i wasn't
getting a great experience and i thought
man i don't want to have the same
process repeat over and over again so i
thought back to ed and ed i met at a
charity event that was helping
entrepreneurs in africa
and uh i gave a call and met up and i
thought you know what this guy seems to
care so i'm going to give him a shot
and from then on ed has been
amazing and he transferred everything
over to my new server he took care of
all the details he didn't charge me
extra for it he gives me recommendations
for improving it and making software
tweaks and he's up sometimes at three in
the morning on a friday night
doing silver upgrades
and the biggest thing that's been so
great is
my site has been up
right like i almost i don't think about
ed anymore which is just kind of sad but
but it's a good thing i don't think
about it because my site is up it works
everything is awesome and ed is
maintaining it and i don't need to talk
to him every week and say why is my site
not working
and so the biggest thing though is ed
cares
he cares he personally gets involved he
wants the person to make sure you're
happy he gets customer service he loves
what we're doing and he's become a part
of the team so ed for those of you who
could check out his website it's bounce
web if you need a good web host but
don't take up too much ed's time because
i still want to make sure
he's solid for my account so thank you
ed it's been awesome
you've had a huge impact on on my
business and just adding the stability
and your your friendliness and your
desire to help has just been amazing so
thank you and for those of you watching
and encourage you to take time today to
thank somebody who's had an impact on
your business make a video write them a
note send them an email go surprise them
with a cup of coffee and a donut
whatever it is just take a little bit of
time out of your day to say thank you
you know you'll feel better they'll feel
better everybody will have a better day
believe for those of you watching you
can subscribe to the channel
to see more videos like this you can
click on the link in the description to
support me and leave a comment let me
know what you think i love seeing those
comments come in they really make a
difference for me thank you so much i'll
see you soon